over the last few years hackings been
introduced into a variety of different
video games in a variety of different
ways
I decided to take a look at a few that
had hacking in their steam tags to see
if they're presented hacking in a
realistic way and if they could make
someone like me with no hacking
experience feel like a real hacker one
of the first games to use hacking as a
core mechanic was 2001 uplink by
introversion software uplink presents
hacking in the stylized hollywood sense
think progress bars EDM and frosted tips
you're given an upgradable gateway
terminal in the uplink corporations
offices that you used to complete
various tasks which are usually
infiltrate X machine which is protected
by Y security protocols
luckily the uplink Corporation has a
bunch of software and rig upgrades to
help you hack into even the most
lockdown system these upgrades are all
reliant on a shared pool of disk space
and memory that prevents you from
throwing everything you can think of at
a problem
you'll also need to bounce your
connection around the world to slow down
traces when you try to connect to a
target machine is it an accurate
representation of hacking no but it did
make me feel like a cyber Punk as I wash
my dial-up connection bounced around the
world while the FBI tried to trace me
one blockbuster series to feature
hacking is ubisoft s-- watchdogs
assuming the role of a dead sack
activist players are able to manipulate
the worlds of Chicago and San Francisco
by exploiting the citywide automation
and security system ctos City OS C very
clever with just the touch of a button
you can bypass a car security system and
controller remotely steal an unreleased
music track from a famous rapper by
bunny hopping from security camera to
security camera or just eavesdrop on an
unsuspecting citizens phone conversation
now while it's presented as hacking it
could just as well be called magic or
superpowers as the games don't really
demand anything from you beyond the
occasional pipe madness star minigame
Quadrilateral cowboy however is watch
dogs if watchdogs required you to write
code every time your character opened a
laptop playing is a team of three
thieves for hire you must plan and
execute a series of increasingly
complicated heists using a
top-of-the-line late 80s or early 90s
hacking deck sporting a 56 point 6 K
modem and 256 K of RAM along with a
suite of other tools that must all be
programmed from a terminal window the
game starts by teaching you to set up
your deck in type
simple command-line to just open a door
but soon you'll be writing complex
command strings to for example open a
door just as a camera is powered down to
your emot-- controlled drone can sneak
past undetected by the final moments of
quadrilateral cowboy I started to feel
like a hacker elite as the command
string note scribbled down on a scrap of
paper was helping me steal in a moveable
safe from the top floor of a skyscraper
but the few notes I took while playing
quadrilateral cowboy when nothing
compared to the pages of scroll I wrote
while playing hack net hack net opens
with a simple screen asking you for a
login and the password after logging in
you're greeted by an ominous message
from a hacker named bit bit is dead and
he needs your help to stop something
hack net doesn't expect you to have any
coding experience and it teaches you
real life terminal commands as you play
early on you're faced with a challenge
that will have you frantically recalling
the commands and processes you've used
once or twice in one of the scariest
most rewarding video game moments I've
ever played hack net is as close to an
accurate real-world hacking sim as you
can get when a games developer Matt
Tribbiani
was asked if he was worried the game
could be training the hackers of the
future he answered knowledge like this
is even more easily used to be helpful
than it is to do harm I do kind of hope
I'm creating the hackers of the future
which is one of the reasons he's working
on an educational version of the game
and that's exactly how I felt as I
bashed commands into the terminal window
in order to read more private emails and
search for the steam codes the developer
hides inside the game with every new
update release so that's just a look at
a few of the hacking games on offer but
there's still a bunch more out there let
me know via Twitter or in the comments
section below any I might have missed
and what are your favorites well I can
subscribe for more videos and I'll catch
you guys next time
[Music]
you
[Music]